[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
abordamos las inquietudes en torno al
kobe 19 y vamos a hablar más
precisamente de la reciente inclusión de
la variante muy en la lista de intereses
de la organización mundial de la salud
por eso nos comunicamos con nuestro
asesor científico en france24 carlos
eduardo pérez en el médico infectólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia
doctor buen día para usted y qué quiere
decir que una nueva variante se incluya
en esta lista de intereses de la
organización mundial de la salud
angela recordemos que las mutaciones
llevan a variantes y hay algunas
variantes que se llaman de interés
porque tienen un impacto en la
transmisibilidad o en el escape al
sistema inmunitario además de eso que se
considere que su transmisibilidad sea
responsable de un pico en cierta región
hay otro tipo de variantes que son de
preocupación o que tienen gran
consecuencia y en la que se estableció
actualmente es una variante interés es
decir que está bajo observación de las
autoridades para ver su comportamiento a
nivel global
teniendo en cuenta doctor que la
variante de él está derivado en el
aumento de contagios en el mundo que
sabemos acerca de los eventuales
peligros de esta variante llamada moho
todas las variantes tienen esa capacidad
de cual y se llaman do interés porque
aumenta la transmitida muy probablemente
y mientras estas variantes estén
circulando y las personas no tengamos la
cobertura vacunal deseada o algunas de
las vacunas fallen incluso para estas
variantes pues seguirá progresando la
pandemia por eso es importante en
monitorizar genómica mente en cada país
que está circulando para poder
determinar cuál es la cepa de linaje
predominante y con eso puede hacer
intervenciones tanto de salud pública
como inmunización para controlar los
brotes pandemia bueno y en qué lugares
del mundo se encuentra ya esta nueva
variante
esta nueva variante fue identificada en
colombia pero no quiere ir que se haya
originado en colombia ya se ha
encontrado en más de 35 países
circulando en muchos en américa del sur
en centroamérica y ya se ha escrito
casos en europa es probable que este
tipo de cepas por su transmisibilidad se
logren aislar en varias partes del mundo
también en los próximos meses bueno lo
estaba diciendo ustedes esta variante
museo detectó por primera vez en
colombia este año que se puede hacer
para que el origen o la
primera aparición de estas variantes en
los países no termine estigmatizando a
esos lugares donde aparecen
si ya incluso por ejemplo no se llaman
de variante como llamábamos ampliamente
el reino unido o sudáfrica ya son letras
del alfabeto griego porque entendemos
que las variantes no se originan en un
país sino son la consecuencia de la
transmisibilidad que hay en la región
mientras hayan personas susceptibles van
a suceder estas variantes que se
detecten en un país no quiere decir que
se originen en ese país y la circulación
de estas variantes va a depender del
comportamiento de los determinantes
humanos y de la sociedad que permiten
controlar o expander en la presencia de
estas variantes bueno y como vemos que
siguen saliendo variantes y que esto es
la norma que va a seguir ocurriendo las
vacunas que ya están en el mercado nos
dan una protección en frente a ellas
en este momento está establecido que
protegen a hay una disminución en la
protección para la infección pero
recordemos que para la enfermedad es
decir las consecuencias graves del coi
mantiene su alta eficacia las vacunas
pero no para la infección es decir que
las personas pueden transmitirlo y ahora
se está evaluando con esta con él se
estaba hablando con esta variante si las
vacunas tienen o no ese impacto de
reducción de la neutralización por así
decirlo sin embargo lo más sensato es
mantener la vacunación rápida eficaz y
masiva para que no vayan a suceder
nuevas variantes bueno doctor y todos
los países están luchando en este
momento por determinar de inmunizar
completamente a su población incluso
algunos están ya aplicando los refuerzos
con terceras vacunas cree usted que se
nos viene pronto la planeación de una
segunda ronda de vacunación
seguramente las terceras dosis no son 27
refuerzos y unas terceras dosis en
población inmune suprimida en personas
madres de 65 años deben ser una
prioridad en el país y en los países
donde están vacunando a este grupo de
personas y muy pronto se deben incluir
las poblaciones de 1 a 12 años para
lograr la inmunidad colectiva en este
momento tenemos que estar vacunando lo
que tenemos presente completar las
pautas completas y luego si llegar a una
tercera dosis gracias doctor ya nuestros
televidentes sigan con nosotros
[Música]